yay yeah I'm Tess I'm famous and we're
gonna have a good time so I'm gonna talk
about the dark sides of machine learning
and hopefully I won't make it to
dystopic and make you scare away from it
too much but when you tell some stories
about how wrong things can go and how it
can make them go right
so about a year and a half ago a couple
of researchers a group of researchers in
California created a machine learning
model that could accurately or at least
accurately according to them figure out
if a crime was gang-related or not so
taking the police report the
perpetrators and the victims where they
were from whether where the crime was
created and a couple of things like that
it's basically say if it was a gang
crime or not so pretty useful in the
cases where they didn't have a police
report they would simply generate one
because this was a very forward-thinking
paperweight using generative neural
networks and things so what could
possibly go wrong with something like
this hmm well it turns out that if you
get classified as a gang member that's
not necessarily a very good thing and
this machine learning model was based on
this database called the cow gang
database California gang related
activity database which has a lot of
people that are pursuing to be gang
members and this database went through
an audit and had some quite severe
problems one of them was privacy so
local businesses could freely look in
here and see if they should hire someone
or not because if they were getting what
they are related they shouldn't it also
had some retention problems so a little
bit like a tile California if you got in
this database you could check out but
not
and then it had some problems in the
night about 25% of the people in hair
we're not actually proven to have any
gang-related affiliations in fact 42 of
the people in this database were babies
under the age of 1 I don't which a full
28 had admitted to being active the gang
members so naturally when this was
presented at a conference like many
machine learning papers are there were
some questions there were some questions
about what did he do to mitigate the
problems with the data how did you make
sure that you didn't just pick a gang
crime because it was someone Hispanic or
black living in a certain zip code what
did you do and the presenter just was
like I'm just an engineer I'm thinking
I'm actually when this happened this guy
Blake Lim one from Google who was in the
room
he gets so flustered and irritated that
he left the room reciting a song by Tom
Lehrer and saying once the Rockets go up
who cares where they fall down in this
song by Tom Lehrer about a burner from
Brown who was a rocket scientist a new
second world war and was Rockets were
meant to land on the moon but I
fortunately landed right here in London
but that was not his department I'm just
an engineer I'm here to suggest that
we're maybe not just engineers maybe we
have a little bit more responsibility
with the things we do because we're put
in charge from some very very
interesting systems that have a lot of
consequence systems that basically tell
you if you should get a job or not if
you should get a loan if you should get
put in jail you should get medical care
live or die essentially so I think we
a little bit more responsibility
essentially Ares don't you just say I'm
an engineer as someone else has to take
care of the rest
or as Todd I puts it in his tweet yeah
we have a little bit more responsibility
I'm sure it being from London your were
well-acquainted with Cambridge analytic
I and many of you have probably seen the
Netflix show which if you haven't it's a
very good one so in this case I will
know what happened basically they they
took a lot of data from from Facebook
made personality analysis figure it out
who was more swayable and then sent
propaganda to those people this research
or the research that led up to this was
loosely based on something else by
Michelle Kosinski so Michelle Kosinski
and you might be familiar with this to
like a couple of years back there was a
big thing I think IBM even had a version
of this where you could enter your
Twitter account or your Facebook account
and would give you sort of like a
personality profile because given 50 of
your likes it could tell you who you
were better than your friends could in
most cases this guy Michelle Kosinski he
didn't do this actually for Cambridge
analytic I hid the disk as proof of this
is a bad thing that we should be careful
of and make sure it doesn't happen
but unfortunately is showing that it can
happen is something that other other
people can build on he also created this
very controversial paper that's commonly
known as the AI gate our paper have any
of you heard of it a few maybe so the a
gate our paper is exactly what it sounds
like you take pictures of people and
these by looking at someone you would be
able to tell what their sexual
orientation is what could possibly go
wrong with this
right so looking at and so you explain
what you're seeing here so this is a
composite picture so what it means like
you average in the pixels of pictures
and you put them together as you're
seeing like the the average female who
likes females female like males male
like males and males or so means who
like females and males were like males
and he said that would very good
accuracy he could figure out yes by
someone's face what their sexual
orientation is now it has some method
problems so mainly it was using pictures
from dating websites a location where
you might be a little bit more explicit
about your orientation but if we think
and actually what it found that was it's
becoming a stereotype detector so you
can see here for example that this
female uses a lot more makeup this great
thing in the forehead is more more uses
for baseball caps and this guy is
completely heterosexual because he
doesn't know how to take selfies so you
can see its nostrils a little bit more
but um so anyways depending on if you
think this could be done or not if we're
going and think about has something like
this and saying and classifying
someone's sexual orientation if we would
classify a cat or a dog something is
either a cat or dog or neither but what
does a one or a zero mean for something
like sexual orientation is a zero
homophobic and it's a one like the
leader of the Pride Parade and where
does like bicurious or bisexual or
gender-fluid or anything like that fit
into this obviously this is a little bit
more complex than Estes ear or one so
classifying a human behavior
as a serial one even if it could be done
technically can't be done because you
have such variation and then what does
it matter for me being from Sweden if
they classify me wrong that probably
wouldn't have a high effect on my life
but east a few years ago having
something else then a heterosexual
lifestyle was classified for books in
the library
in mental disorders because things like
this classifications like these have a
very very long tail and now I live in
Sweden but if I would live in another
country it might even be something
that's a criminal offence
sometimes punishable by death so it does
have a lot of consequence doing
something like this speaking of
criminals another set of researchers
this time in China set out to create a
criminality detector what could possibly
go wrong with that so what he did was
they took a number of pictures of men
from 18 to 55 and yes by looking at
their faces they could determine if they
were criminals or not excellent
so they took 2,000 pictures of men and a
couple of them were criminals some we're
not criminals out of the criminals some
were violent and you might think like
Ashley accurate they classify something
like this you would have to create like
classify super violent criminals or
something like that somewhere where you
could really see maybe on someone's face
if they were a hardened criminal
but now a lot of the people that they
could classify as criminals were simply
like they would do fraud or other petty
crime now this also had some method
problems shall we say
it when they looked at the pictures
again after the composite pictures
criminal non criminal they found very
scientifically that what what made you
mainly a criminal or a non criminal
learned picture was this triangle up
here if we take a look at that again ow
that's either a frown or smile actually
and the method problem they had was they
took pictures from corporate headshots
for the non criminals and
government-issued IDs for the criminals
hmm yeah wouldn't quite clearly see how
difficult it would be to to distinguish
between the two
so anyways they had 90 percent accuracy
nine out of ten times the kid figurative
style which was extraordinary because at
a time the biggest or the best
architecture for neuron networks was
Alex net for for image neural networks
and it could classified gender in
eighty-six percent of the cases mm-hmm
nothing fishy there so they know you
ever gotten a speeding ticket
I don't worry you don't have to put your
hands up Alex that can see it in your
face
but now if we think about this because
this is another human behavior this may
be not so one Hertz zero because what
actually constitutes a criminal in this
case and if you were to think about like
how would this actually work looking at
someone's face it would have to work in
one of two ways first time I steal a pen
at my office my bone structure changes
right either that or I'm born a criminal
there's only one of two ways but a
criminality detector could work still
this is going on and this is used not
this particular model but model ceased
like this one are used so the question
is maybe not can we do it but should we
do it one of my former colleagues I'm
saying former colleagues because we work
at the same company in Microsoft but
I've actually never met her Kate
Crawford she's now a director of AI now
in for AI and ethics she said we're
currently in the biggest classification
experiment of our times or in human
history it's not like we haven't done
this before many times throughout
history Aristotle is was doing this but
we're now doing it at scale without
anyone knowing and by people well who is
not understanding that they're even
doing this and it's making it into
products that are actually induced and
bought by a real governments this Gary
people right and the problem is
that as soon as we put it in an
algorithm it becomes the truth so one of
my friends and I'm not sure if you're
here both but he went to a hardware
store he was remodeling his house with
his wife and he went to a hardware store
to buy some two by fours got two two by
fours
they were clearly labeled with the
hardware store name and took them to the
counter the counter had the person that
counters
I looked at him his wife the
two-by-fours and said we don't carry
those because the computer said nope
right so even looking at a two by fours
at the people in front of him and
everything he's still trusted the
computer and to some extent even I trust
a computer like this soon as soon as it
get put and gets put in an algorithm it
sort of comes to truth it's like a
responsibility laundering because
suddenly it's the computer that dust is
I mean we all trust banks even though we
know that the people who are working at
the banks creating these systems also
have Friday's where they don't
necessarily look at the PRS all that
closely right we're just letting it
happen but maybe it's because we trust
computers to not have the same faults
this way so we know that people are
biased that's how we survived that's how
we do shortcuts and how we actually get
through life but the computer doesn't
have any feelings it doesn't have any in
a biased it can't be racist but I do
have partially the same problems as us
so I have to admit I'm not a big star
Wars fan
in fact I fell asleep on all the Star
Wars movies I did go because it is my
duty as a computer engineer but I still
fall asleep so I couldn't tell Chewbacca
from his wife or his son because I
haven't had a huge amount of exposure to
wookies so because of that I can also
not tell exactly what distinguishes them
in the same way a machine learning model
can only understand the things that it
actually has seen and for computer
vision the things that most computer
vision systems have seen is this image
net it's a fantastic database of images
huge database of images
millions of images of searches on the
Internet
now it has a little bit of an issue in
that being that it searches from the
Internet in English the majority of the
pictures in here are from the US and
Europe in fact there is like very very
little from Africa and and the very big
countries of China and India have like 3
percent in total or pictures in here so
that means that when we have a computer
vision system and maybe in like
cognitive services and we give it this
picture it shows this right because
that's our latest scene but it's part
similarly when we look at face
recognition systems we have a benchmark
that is commonly known as labeled faces
in the wild so this is a benchmark
database of Yahoo News images headshots
from Yahoo News from 2002 to 2004 and
most face recognition systems have been
benchmarked against this now if you
picture who was in the news in 2002 to
2004 it will be 77% male 80% white and
actually a full 5 percent
george w bush
and actually like if you look at the
women who are in here they're either
Hillary Clinton which I hope I don't
look like her or actresses which I could
expire but I'm not looking like her
either
and like them either but um so face
recognition systems are extremely
tailored to your CH w bush which becomes
a little bit of a problem because when
you create systems that are based on
face recognition you get things like
this if you don't train them on enough
of the population that you're actually
targeting well you get things like this
where if I go through and I look at
myself and my age and things I'm very
happy that it's guessing twenty-six
yay I'm not 26 but I'm also not a male
which is a little bit of a different
problem
this woman joy well when we I think I'm
mangling her name badly but boom weenie
she's doing a lot of face recognition
research and as you can see in the
pictures he's wearing him white mask the
reason for this white mask is because
she's not visible to many of the face
recognition systems out there it's not
like they don't recognize that she's
joyful woman II they don't recognize
that she's a person like she's too dark
for most face recognition systems that's
the scary thing she's doing a lot of
research wearing this mask we still have
done a lot of research because of her
problems with this on how face
recognition works for different
different groups of people and in 2018
early I think she went through the
bigger face recognition systems at a
time and she discovered that while they
all professed like a nice almost 100%
accuracy and gender accuracy it turns
out is very very different for different
for different people so
someone like a light male has like a
good hundred percent accuracy they will
always be classified as male where
where's the dark female in the IBM
system for example one out of three
times
she'll be classified as male okay
obviously a little bit of a problem a
problem that causes things like this so
last summer two summers ago and they had
in London bunch of CCTV cameras and they
had this watch for for coming late and
like common criminals and they went out
they found this guy and went out with
the SWAT car patted him down and it
turned out it just wasn't him
because he's like with the Wookiees
these face recognition systems can tell
a dark-colored person from another
dark-colored person which is yeah it's
not good
however some things have been done to
fix this in most I made your face
recognition systems so IBM went out and
created another benchmark system I have
because of the work of Joey Bulwer
meaning and there's a lot more diverse
and has helped a lot with the with a
first sample with IBM face plus plus and
Microsoft some still have problems and
there is a big debate and kind of like
pie-throwing about whether this research
is good or bad but I'm hoping that day
two we'll fix it so algorithms are using
math so they can't be racist there's a
little bit of what I call bias
laundering because it's not about the
algorithm it's nothing necessarily it's
about of data we haven't and it's not
used images that have this problem we
have this problem in text too so the way
text works or the way machine learning
works around text is that we're trying
to
create some sense of what a word means
so for example if you have the word
peach and Beach they sound very similar
but we know that peach and Beach have
very little commonalities right so in
order to do some machine learning and
understanding we need ten state
understand a real meaning between the
word peach and understand it may be
affricate would be a more similar word
from the beach so in order to do this
we'll look at a large amount of data and
we'll find out like semantics and what
you find then is sort of like not a
dictionary meaning but the common
meaning of the word and all all the
places that it's been used and the
context has been used so if we enter in
Google Translate she's a computer
programmer and he's a nurse and
translate back to Turkish and then
translated back it will show the true
meaning of what Google thinks a computer
programmer or a nursing because this is
the context of days right it thinks it
the majority of places where it's
planned computer programmer is male
context so it finds days it actually
also has this for many other things like
he is beautiful she's aggressive she's
guilty I've been not a translator okay
so all of the words have some kind of of
like male or female context yes
actually also have a lot of other
contexts like ethnic context and things
like that what is something like this
causes also a lot of problems so let's
say you have a text prediction system
you start off with this sentence and
then you type in the word he and then
you see what the computer suggests and
it will suggest something like this
right the doctor hired the assistant
because he was too busy but on the other
hand if you put in the word she it would
put in something like this
right because that is the context is
inferring from this so things like this
cause some real problems like when
Amazon was trying to create like CV
selector and it right little removed
things like gender and things like that
however the wording that we use gives us
a way and it gives us a way in the sense
that it already knew that execute is a
very male word very not very often used
by females and things like that makes it
then distinguish between them what is a
good or a bad candidate so it causes so
things like they cost us a little bit of
a confirmation bias bubble it causes it
to always choose what we were always
chosen not necessarily because they're
factually the best or factually like
what it should be but because we have a
bias we have historical bias that tells
us what but a computer in there should
traditionally be male for example it
also causes and what are call feedback
loops so feedback loop go something like
this about 5% of the CEOs are female
that's the fact we can try to change
that but right now that's how it works
so when you see the results for the word
CEO you'll get something like this now
the problem is that if you get a search
result on on google or on bing or
wherever you click you normally just
click in the top 5% maybe you're it is
hot like three four rows and the more
you click these the more that will
become the truth so whatever majority
you have will be sort of like feedback
and now not only will it go from like
five ninety five it will turn into like
in mind in mind one ratio because you're
just sort of like automating this bias
you're creating it bigger and bigger
similarly if you have a location where
you have a lot of crime two men you go
in and you send in a lot of police and
you arrest more people now the perceived
situation here is that you have even
more climbing in this area right so then
you send in more police and more arrests
and it just goes on and feed backs away
similarly to how you always see the same
things on Facebook you always listen to
the same music on Spotify you get into
these recursive feedback loops the mist
sort of like you lose the the minority
for me in this so in the words of Bora
real bora devops part of course to make
an error is human but to propagate the
error to our server in automatic ways is
DevOps if we translate this to aii
forget this some bias like how do i deal
with it because bias is sort of like an
np-hard problem i say empty heart
because there's so many different
variables here that no matter what roots
will go down there will always be one
more root but if we haven't explored
right so for the words we could
technically and it's been done and it's
it works we could remove the male-female
bias and we could used say computer
engineers are neutral and that's you can
use remove sort of that factor of the
word and it would work so great why
don't we use that well it turns out that
is not necessarily that easy
because there are some words somewhere
for example mother or father they should
have a very high like gender bias but
what about something like colorblind or
pregnant or queen like should they have
a gender prize and if you start too
little
if you start thinking about things like
that it becomes a little bit more
complicated and even more complicated
when you realize that once you remove
the gender bias you might want to remove
the ethnicity bias which is not just
like a two thing just like many things
so I have to like start them all against
each other and maybe you want to remove
the bias of like political affiliation
and sexual orientation and all these
things and suddenly it becomes a very
very difficult problem so to give an
example of another way this is also
difficult if we look at alone and we say
okay so we're gonna create like a credit
card algorithm something that should
tell us if this person should have
credit or not so we should remove gender
and remove a lot of other things like
ethnicity in proxies for them but then
we realized that it might still serve
like be giving less credit to women than
to men because women normally have like
big gaps in their employment history
like one and a half year gaps here and
there and maybe two or three in a
lifetime coinciding made when you had
children and that of course causes a
problem so maybe we would then decide
that we should have equal outcome like
equal outcome would mean that if we have
a hundred women and hundred men an equal
amount of the women and the men should
be getting credit cards but that would
also cause a problem because what if all
the females are not qualified and all
the males are qualified now you're kind
of removing credit cards for some people
that were obviously qualified and giving
them to some that were not qualified so
Noah might go through and say oh we
should have equal opportunity meaning
that given the the same qualifications
you should have an equal opportunity so
you shouldn't be penalized for being a
man or a woman but then we realize that
all of these things become a very very
political
question and not so much a technical
question we realize that maybe while
we're in short if there is and while
we're responsible as engineers we also
need to bring in some other perspectives
and domain knowledge into this equation
if we don't we might in with a scandal
and like the Apple card so this is I
think the crater of Ruby on Rails
started is for all about the apple cart
being sexist and then as the wasps Nick
came in and he also thought that and
then wired came in and also thought that
and it might very well be that it wasn't
that the reason Hawaii vas Nick's wife
didn't get the same credit limit was
because she didn't make as much money or
for many of the other reasons but the
problem here is that we don't know that
and contradict here too for example if
you have normal credit card
you kind of know when you make an
application that it looks at your credit
history it looks like whatever you
filled in with that sort of where the
buck stops whereas if we have an Apple
credit card or a saloon kind of like a
lot of thoughts that go into your head
that maybe it's also looking at x y&z
and all the other data that I'm giving
away to Apple so the problem here is
maybe not the algorithm but the
transparency around the algorithm
causing causing this so not only have do
you have to make sort of take care of
the bias and the political questions
around it but also around transparency
and making sure that people understand
what the decisions are based on whether
they are based on gender which I don't
think actually there was a person at
Apple a little Goldman Sachs in this
case that when Tina said maelys ten
times the credit history of women I
don't even think that they looked and
maiden made sure I was certified
Rockstar developer before getting the
Apple credit card
but still things like this come up
because they weren't very transparent so
what do we do do we just give up because
it seems like so hard that there is like
really no solution to this obviously I
wouldn't be here if I thought that so
what I've done specifically is I'm in an
AI ethics committee yet in Microsoft
sort of like looking at all the products
that were working on and we have some
specific agendas or specific points that
we're looking through for all the
products and the specific ones that
we're looking at are if it's fair and
inclusive if it's transparent does
everyone in the in the process
understand where the data comes from and
how the decisions are made with machine
learning you can't know exactly but you
can at least have an inkling
understanding the data and is it
accountable so when something goes wrong
is there a person there or is there
someone who can actually say yeah you
know I understand the problem we have
we're going to look at it and like
actually fix the problems that come up
making sure that it's safe and reliable
like autonomous cars and or and the
systems that decide if you should get
treatment or not and secure and private
so these are the five things that we
look at specifically when we go through
the process the first thing and there's
a colleague of mine he is that he says
what is the worst possible headline what
could possibly go wrong with this this
is the first question we always ask
ourselves about any machine learning
product that we work on so that at least
we have a base and this is like where we
get like super creative about things
that could cut it and potentially go
wrong because then you have to decide
are they worth it and if they're worth
it because in some cases you actually do
want something for the benefits it gives
but you have to mitigate the problems
that didn't let my erase so for example
some problems are quite easy to spot
should you have a credit card system
based on social ratings or should you
have a criminality detector I think sort
of like the black mirror episodes right
themselves so in my mind - obvious no
but then you have something like things
you have should you have something in
that spots cancer like tells you if it's
benign ormaline and obviously the
problem where they say state if you get
it wrong it's fatal it's like very
dangerous to get this wrong but it's
also sometimes very dangerous to not
have this system at all so in that case
you have to figure out how you can sort
of take that and say okay so we're
obviously not going to do an automated
system instead we should have something
maybe that speeds up the process or
helps doctors but always keeping a human
in the loop or a pigeon in the booth as
you see fit and then if you have some
things that you go I can't see what
could possibly go wrong with this like
for example I'm sorry I guess creating
in our meat detector it like something
that you take in a picture and it says
it's a cat it's a dog like you know he's
for fun until he end up with this
situation right and I don't think anyone
and I'm thinking we can be sure if that
no one has made this label or even
thought to put this label in there but
in case like that you still have to have
a rapid response system to understand
how to fix this because obviously this
was very involuntary but also very
consequential so understanding the
problem then we have the historical and
data and the historical data might
contain biases that we can either want
or not want so in a case like this we
might say okay so we know that five
percent of CEOs are women and the rest
are men and and that's our past but that
might
I don't want to make that our future so
in a case like that who might go in and
infuse you know some some infused you
couldn't you've used women whatever like
infusing a few women in this search
result to make sure we don't run into
that run of a feedback loop or in the
case of Spotify maybe sometimes
suggesting something that's a little bit
off to keep things interesting
in fact with Spotify they have a really
interesting historical problem so over
Christmas I'm guessing I was not the
only one to listen to Mariah Carey but
I'm also like after a 25th
I'm not big Mariah Carey that I'm sorry
to say so I don't want my whole sort of
like everything else modified to be
Mariah Carey from then on so there's
history and there it endures history in
the short term so we have to be
conscious about what our history tells
us and not just sort of go on that some
other things that are quite obvious is
for example if you do a house price
estimator and then two years later some
law was passed then the house price
estimator is not working anymore so your
historical data it's not working as a
fix for that but in this case you can do
I have something political or you can do
something and technically unstated and
then even if your data would be perfect
you might still have selection bias so
selection bias is probably the most
common way to introduce a problem in a
machine learning system selection bias
means that we're obviously not going to
sample the whole world for anything so
as an example this was an application
that and was supposed to fix potholes
this was in 2011 and I put this here for
reference because what they did was they
had an app on iPhone and it would sort
of like sense when you were driving on
the street and if it was
and vibrating or if it was moving a lot
it would sense a pothole and would
report it back and it was great
however it only found potholes in the
very rich districts of Boston any
guesses on why
maybe hmm yeah cuz maybe the iPhones
were sort of like in that particular
area so you're sampling like how your
sample makes a lot of difference if
you're standing outside of a retirement
home or if you're standing outside of a
daycare center and do a poll you'll
probably get a lot different results as
far as like how you should use your tax
money and similarly the way we've
sampled imagenet as a problem so every
sampling we do will introduce the bias
of the people doing the sampling but
also serve like the available data that
we have so one way that we can work with
this is by actually documenting how we
did things and the limitation is off of
these data sets and then we go to select
features and proxies so look at crime
for example and saying that an arrest
means crime is using a proxy you might
think that arrest equals crime and in a
lot of cases maybe it does but there are
also some crimes that never go and get
like some criminals that never get
arrested and some criminals some non
criminals that do get arrested so the
arrest is a lot of the biown a lot in
the bias off police people in the areas
that you live in and things like that
similarly if you look at a diagnosis
that's in the bias of a doctors so using
something like proxied like that who
will also change your system a lot and
then we have the models so choosing a
model you can either choose a very
simple model in a very simple model
you'll end up with a problem that if 95%
of your computer engineers are mailed
then all you
computer engineers on male but if you
choose something that is like a little
bit too complex it will learn like the
exact thing you taught it so it will not
generalize well so if you ask what color
is lemon might say yellow and then you
ask which color is a lemon and it might
give you a totally different answer
although you're sort of asking the same
question and then you might ask which
color is lemon and guess just crazy
right so um the next thing is evaluation
so we've already seen problems with
evaluation and with the banish mark
systems but there's also so you can
actually fix this a little bit by using
tools like the Google what if tool that
allows you to slice the data by
different things so slice the data by
gender and make sure you get the results
like a similar result for for the
genders or for the mr. D and things like
that but you also have different
measuring problems so let's say you have
a scissor problem like this you have
your gonna create a fraud detector and
you have a system that has for every
thousand transactions it has one fraud
transaction now if you wanted to have
99.9 percent accuracy on your machine
learning model you could simply write
this right yay yeah so this kind of
proves how easy it is to fool the system
and this is what will happen this is
what a machine learning model will
actually learn if you just go by
accuracy obviously here you want to
slice in my sage and want to make sure
that the accuracy for the fraud is high
but this is sort of like how the
problems creep in like the label faces
and the world problems and then there is
the way that you use and the systems so
sometimes when they use the system
you might have a problem that you're
giving away things that you shouldn't
necessarily give away so it's because
you've learned something it doesn't
necessarily mean that you don't should
show it so let's say for example you do
an autocorrect system it will learn from
everything you tie and it might be hello
but consequentially if it always shows
the things that you normally type in the
wrong context or also something like
this where it correctly learned that his
teenager was pregnant but maybe she
didn't necessarily wanted to give that
away to her parents in the newsletter
from Target so you have to think a
little bit about how you technology
could be used and how it will be used so
one big thing that a lot of people are
talking about is this perpetual lineup
thing and be using the CCTV cameras and
using face detection to automatically
find criminals person of interest style
I for want to think that this is a very
scary thing that is happening because um
it kind of limits us in in our growth as
a society and what I mean by that is for
example if you if you look at first
teenagers if you control and see where
ever they go who they're with how are
they possibly going to rebel and
understand themselves and grow and
become bigger people because people have
to be able to make mistakes and people
have to like society might change so if
we would have had a system where
everything was controlled and criminals
were sort of like caught on sight a
number of years ago then having like I
think a relationship would be would not
be something that we could have right
now or if you're into that like smoking
pot in the u.s. because that would have
been caught and still didn't like no one
could ever rebound and create new ways
of thinking
so I think if you're creating if you
have a system and something that could
be used like that in a totalitarian way
you also need to make sure that it's not
used like that so it's a bigger company
or a bigger player you have to put your
stakes down and say that this is not how
I should use it specifically also
knowing that it has these biases it has
these problems that will make things
worse for a certain population or
minorities in the system likewise I'm
sure you've seen deep fakes deep fakes
are basically creating videos where you
can make someone look like they're
saying something that are not actually
saying so a quite an easy way to create
fake news so I'm happy that the big five
got together and posted a very big
healthy sum of money to the people that
could mitigate this and sort of like
find eesti fakes another thing and that
I think is important in this is to have
diverse teams so have someone that
actually speaks up because it's not
always to put your easy to put yourself
in someone else's shoes and understand
like all the different possibilities
that could come up like for example when
Facebook created a system for saying
which names were okay or not and didn't
necessarily think that long names
containing proper nouns were appropriate
this happens or when car manufacturers
don't really think up women as drivers
and not her crash test dummies that that
are appropriate sized for women in fact
up to 2003 there was no female crash
test dummies and what would we do if we
didn't have any British people in our
teams someone who could tell us if we
should pour the milk first or second
yeah
so and then we also need to understand
that no matter what we do
Eris will creep up things will happen so
in this case obviously they thought what
could possibly go wrong with this or
maybe someone maybe no-one thought that
but he used face recognition technology
to to send jaywalkers texts perfect like
you don't even have to have a police in
the loop in there but then this happens
like this lady was on the on the bus she
gets a lot of tickets so obviously then
you have to have system to to fix that
but after all is said and done and if
you look at all these things and and try
to fix them as best you can the one
thing I want to leave you with is that
just like all these people joy below me
neo Chris Wiley all these when you see
something wrong or something that
doesn't fit or something that just feels
like they should have really thought
with what the heck should go wrong with
this speak up because we're not just
engineers we are the guardians of our
future thank you
[Music]
you